welcome back to the Rich Eisen show and
welcome back to one of my favorite
guests that I have here she's got a new
stand-up special on Netflix it's her
fourth stand-up special and it you know
a best-selling author and maybe the
creation of two Broke Girls help pay for
the robot general right she is none of
them Whitney Cummings good to see you I
don't know all I know is you're you're
sitting in the the a position guest seat
and to your right is a remarkable
look-alike it's like a Penn & Teller
situation well I mean it's it's really
up to you because I think that she's
going everywhere you're going right and
by the way I take offense at the fact
that one of your cameraman called her a
dummy how dare you is that true the
dummy what fully functioning robot that
thinks and talks and that you can have
sex with nobody has yet but to the
highest bidder you may take her
virginity Chris just looked a little too
excited he's looking underneath the desk
for some reason I was gonna see how much
money I had my wallet was attempting to
ask a legitimate question where did the
Cubs Jersey come from that's on your
robot look-alike okay so I'm from
Washington DC yes you are the Orioles
are our team and the Orioles are
definitely yes understand the PR on the
DC baseball not so good
so my fiancee is in a Cubs fan so I got
a Cubs Jersey with my name on the back
okay and we're on a sports show the
sports show so I said put that [ __ ] in
a Cubs Jersey know you probably hate the
Cubs you're a Yankees fan
I am a Yankees fan but I respect the
Cubs I respect I respect how long your
fiancee had to wait good point not just
you it meant the Cubs by the way tell
you if when you're looking for a
possible mate patience is key that's why
I like I want to marry
right exactly the way they'll weight
over a hundred years a patient man and
be married to me so now or is she her
name is Whitney as well or her name is
bear claw watch special you'll know why
she talks you can ask her questions she
couldn't fully talk okay what do you got
right here
how are the Jets hmm
you know what do I answer do I answer
this to you you hear that you if you
hold that up a closer to your microphone
what was that last part right there rich
we tried to program in Laveen Bell I
don't think it sounded right can help
the rich the CEO of the New York robots
are racist cuz they can't pronounce that
name okay but you can fully talk to her
you guys her questions she has all kinds
of questions can we talk about the fact
that your favorite movie is you've got
now yeah Chris can we talk about the
fact that your favorite movie is you've
got married sure it's a great movie but
why your favorite was not my favorite
movie the fact is is that he he loves
the film because it reminds him of a
very special time in his life or a time
would you say that was where you were
yeah my mom surprised me my freshman
year Kyle on a weekend I saw the movie
and so I just kind of think of her Olson
exactly the fact though that I keep
trying to make it sound like it's his
favorite other questions when are you
two getting hair and prints did you
really ask if I'm getting when am I
getting hair implants
okay she's very calm going when I get in
here and plan that's her just mocking
you sometimes she'll just repeat what
you say and then make you feel stupid
about the thing you just said so people
keep asking what she can do you can
program in things
for her to say but you can also just ask
her random questions and I never know
what she's gonna say
one of which questions you have what do
you want to ask do you know any I bet
she knows more about sports than any of
you okay why did Andrew Luck retire okay
I asked her then wait hold on
okay why did I Andrew Luck retire that's
okay so I'm gonna put her in chat mode
oh look out I know it's not great okay
why did Andrew Luck retire I don't know
why it happened but we should try to
figure it out one of the most nuanced
takes on me I mean that was already
right there most than half of the Sports
Talk community more nuanced take sports
cuz you guys know that I suck at sports
and every time I come down this show I
feel bad but I can ask her anything and
learn okay do you know Tom Brady okay
I'll try not to do that too much cuz
every time I ask about Tom Brady she
talks too much about it okay who is Tom
Brady Thomas Edward Patrick Brady jr. is
an American football quarterback for the
New England Patriots of the National
Football League I recommend every woman
that doesn't want to learn about sports
get one of these and she'll talk to your
husband or boyfriend about this Whitney
Cummings here on the Rich Eisen show my
so I think I saw cuz I follow you on
Instagram yeah this is really you you
got this done of yourself yeah I mean
lapped her ID now look like fifty years
older than her already somehow so we're
gonna have to figure out a way to equal
us out he does have remarkable ski days
we got her made I basically thought it
was gonna be a joke like you know you
live with a comic it was like I was
talking about sex robots for like half
an hour in the special I went down to
the sex robot Factory
sounds like let me just make sure I'm
not endorsing something really creepy
like I don't know what's going on sure
went down there like you want us to get
one made of you and I just got engaged
and I don't have time to talk to him and
I was like well does it talk like can it
talk to people they're like I was like
I'm in add to cart' I never thought it
would look
I thought it was gonna look like a like
Chucky like I thought it was gonna look
like a scarecrow like crack-whore like
she can actually talk and do stuff so I
had her come out at the end of the
special and do some comedy well so how
long did it take for you to actually sit
for this thing I had to sit there with a
thing plastered over my face for like I
think was like three hours and I had to
go a couple times and they had to do my
teeth in my ears like I put it all at
the end of the special there's a little
like teaser that explains how it was
done right um but her body's just like a
dead corpse body I mean she can't really
do much genes are very nice they felt
you know what that's a very loaded
charge you know it feels like my fiance
I left my fiance alone with her for like
two days first like he hates er he's
creepy I don't like it one of you is
more than enough like he can't stand it
yes but one time I left him at home her
at home with him and I came back I was
touring and he was like I don't like her
we need to move her up into the closet
like I don't want her out and then he
was like but you know her boots like
feel like boobs I was like what happened
what happened while I was gone by the
way for the radio audience the 2-shot of
the two of you is absolutely freaky I
mean she's a little unbelievable yeah
she's not sitting these like you have
your legs crossed and everything I had
but that is freaking me out right now is
the future it's happening how but look
here's some other stuff that I can do
okay
she's um not blinking and stuff normally
she's looking around I think I like
screwed up with her it's so good um but
she's um you know she's fully
functioning she has a full Anatomy I'm
willing to auction off her virginity
we're gonna work on that at some point
you can't afford it Chris but it's kind
of cool it's like I mean specials night
you have to do something that's like
memorable you know and I just wanted to
do something that was kind of shocking
why are you not afraid of robots every
single time I'm on Twitter and I see
robots jumping and running and opening
doors and walking dogs I'm thinking we
are all dead well she's basically a
corpse she can't do any of those things
oh she but see now
program Oh hold on something's wrong
with her something's wrong with the
Wi-Fi so she's not hooked up so she's
like any woman she's giving us now the
silent treatment because we made fun of
her so that's that so you're your
fiancee is now is a Cubs fan as you
point out does that mean that you're now
more into sports
I'm more into sports I've been to some
Cubs games okay I was very good at going
I took lots of selfies and I posted them
okay so I got the corner of my eye but
that's it but I'm learning about sports
and next time I come on the show she's
gonna be you know you don't have to come
now like you know all expert cuz I'm
from DC my football team you can't even
say the name of them without being
racist I don't even I think where did we
land on changing the name of the
Redskins I have pitches half past never
well cuz I Dan Schneider does not want
to change the name of the Redskins do
you know I've got the name for it if
they want what Washington Americans
really yes you don't even have to change
the look I'm in the middle of something
you don't even have to change the logo
no but he doesn't want to change the
logo cuz it says Redskins everywhere
what about just change it you can keep
half the logo and just change it to four
skins tell me people wouldn't tune in to
see that mask I just think that's that's
got some issues with it I don't know if
you've really thought that completely
through she could not find an issue with
sirplease because her face is not moving
she's got palsy who is this she's not on
Wi-Fi
Benson is that his name what's that this
is Benton who helps me operate the robot
Benton its othor can you just make sure
her face starts working she's you know
it's good because everyone thinks I had
Botox and then I sit next to her and
they look uh Wendy's face moves a lot
Whitney is very animated but uh but yeah
so I'm learning but it's just
frustrating because I need a team like
I'm taking submissions on a football
team to be a fan of well you've got to
here in Los Angeles now one of them late
of the Super Bowl last year in the Rams
do you think that that should be who I
root for
you think you think Patriots well we're
Bram's season ticket-holders so yeah
jump on board yeah as a matter of fact
hey half the time if you want to go to
the game he's more than happy to sell
you that's the least stress to support
well the Patriots cuz they always make
the Superbowl so you can just kind of
write that in she's at least stressed
these stressful teams we have to worry
about the season gonna be in sex rings
no players that are gonna do sketchy
things
colors there's one here's one for you I
think you got the Rams where's the
stadium is it in Inglewood yeah thank
you
you know wait you see it on the way out
is it nice it's well it's being built
okay when's it gonna be done then next
year
I'm that kind of time I need a team now
right now okay the Chargers are just
down the road they're in Carson Raiders
are moving to Vegas what a nightmare you
know what right that I could do I have
some old Raiders jerseys that are really
cute that I got on Etsy like the black
and white I like the I like the colors
do you play Vegas do you do that I do
Vegas quite a bit okay
I love playing in Vegas I think we've
staged the Raiders are gonna do well in
Vegas you can people wanted to see
sports in Vegas oh my gosh yes oh my god
can you imagine those crowds what a
nightmare have you ever done that
Southwest flight LA to Vegas on a
Thursday night
sonic strippers and drunk gangs can you
imagine going to spy have you been a
sporting event yeah I think that we have
no there's been really very few in Vegas
but I have not been to one I would love
to go to a football game in Las well I
bet the cheerleaders are gonna be
awesome
what do you think you think they might
look to the like the one to your right
now she's moving she's back she went off
Wi-Fi free I think she just got bored of
our conversations there she is so you
did your you did your show from your
hometown in Washington I did I did I
shot my special in Washington DC and I
had to specifically say the audience if
anyone is in Redskins Jersey you're not
allowed to be in the front two rows
because then I'm gonna get canceled so
we had to make a special announcement
that was like please no Redskins jerseys
even though I grew up there what's their
basketball team
how are they doing the Wizards not too
good not great
no but the gnats then Washington
Nationals might make the playoffs oh
that's good
that's exciting okay DC it's a matter of
fact in Ashton the Nets might play the
Cubs for the right to win a one game
elimination I'm getting a divorce then
that this is not going well if there is
anything look III don't I'm not fully
well versed in your relationship with
your fiancee you're not I'm not but I
will say this he doesn't follow you and
as a as it I like to follow on Twitter
no but I will say this as a sports fan
mm-hmm if he is this the way you test
your his love for you okay that you
start if the Nats plays how much money
you give me oh okay
the Nats play the Cubs in the playoffs
you should you should just show up the
day that that's on TV your cuz your
fiance's get ready to root for the Cubs
the seasons on the line that's it this
is it the manager may not be back it's
the me there's a lot going on okay okay
you show up full-on Nats Jersey okay
okay
have it's a Bryce Harper on the back
because he left them okay it's an extra
trolling thing okay show up in a Bryce
Harper Nats Jersey okay and route for
the next like you've never rooted for
anything before like it's the greatest
biggest thing in your life okay right in
front of your fiance he's trying to
focus and root for the Cubs it will be
the biggest test of his relationship
with you okay you might want to kick you
out of the house right on I think it
might be a bigger than cuz his sister
married a Rickett okay so now could get
very awkward this could be like a major
portrayal if the games in Wrigley yeah
then you go with tickets that way yeah
how do you like yeah what are the vows
sickness and health
in World Series wildcard goosies I do
try to show up at our wedding and
announce Terzi do you still do and again
I just if you are gonna do this I Bryce
Harper and that's Jersey Bryce Harper
champion someone write that down Bryce
Dallas Howard say betty was doing it but
right now he's trying to figure out why
Oh nope you're yeah she's she's not
blinking we are work on y'all's Wi-Fi
you're the success of your robots
personality is directly correlated to
the strength of your Wi-Fi and I
understand we're here at 18 is streaming
you've got mail on his computer so he's
taking up all of the good Wi-Fi support
Dave Chappelle's in this movie Dave
Chappelle is in you've got mail what I
will bet you your dolls virginity words
he's never said before good to see you
thank you Whitney Cummings can I touch
it available now for streaming on
Netflix come back anytime please bring
your friend to my dummy
[Music]
check it out again on Netflix Whitney
Cummings new fourth stand-up special
we're back with more to set up the rest
of the week we're all heading off ton on
a flight we'll tell you why and what's
going on in the next couple days on the
rich Isis for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app